thank you
I got four seasons looking so good we've
got chainsaw man mob bleach we've got so
many shows so much to talk about I can't
wait to make the full anime season video
it's still technically four for two more
weeks right guys okay I know the
seasonal rundown is a little later than
usual but to be fair I was a bit
preoccupied in October
I think America is fun but you know
after six weeks of driving all over the
states doing shows in 22 different
cities living my life out of a bus
eating far too many hamburgers I am
American out I just need to forget about
the US for a bit all right I need the
most Un-American thing on this anime
show right now chainsaw man wait no
there's got a bunch of American movie
references my hero Academia
[ __ ] no Akiba made Wars all right here
we go there's nothing more Japanese than
Idol concerts and made cafes alright now
we're the furthest we can possibly be
from American culture
[Music]
everything
all right guys you know how it is boxu
is my favorite Japanese snack box I talk
about this every month they are the
premium Japanese snack box that sources
snacks from all over Japan working with
family businesses from all over the
country to send you a new theme of
goodies every month and you know I've
got to be honest since I've been
traveling America for six weeks I have
missed Japanese foods and Japanese
snacks so I'm actually really happy I've
got a box here right now look at all
this look at that when you first become
a boxy subscriber the first box you will
receive is called Seasons of Japan which
is the box I have here giving you a
small little taste of what's to come
because after that each month will be a
different themed box each box is
completely packed and also comes with a
booklet that teaches you all about the
snatch unique flavors and where they
come from or as you can see I'm in the
office and I haven't had dinner yet so
I'm absolutely starving so I'm gonna try
some uni rice crackers so let's see how
these are gonna taste
oh my god oh this is hitting the spot
this is so good all right let's try
something sweet after that this one
caught my eye this is a white strawberry
I love strawberries so let's see how
this one tastes
hmm guard drum this is so good honestly
those snacks were great so if you want
to give a gift to any travel lover anime
lover or food in your life boxu is the
perfect gift so what are you waiting for
if you want to unbox you in your life
click the link in the description and
use code gig up 15 for 15 off your first
purchase thank you very much the boxy
for sponsoring us today and back to the
video
let's start things off with an Easter
guy
wait wait wait hold on I swear I don't
know if I'm enjoying the show too much
or just the right amount the show is
simultaneously the edgiest tryhardy
Sakai junk yet so dumb and ridiculous
that it parodies the isakai genre itself
I mean just look at this main character
we've got another Kirito looking Edge
Lord that super opium gets all the
chicks right right except he spends all
his time trying to be a side character
only to fail and be the protagonist his
superpower isn't his magic or black goo
it's whatever dumb [ __ ] he comes up with
on the spot is true and has been true
the entire time the dude is isakai
Haruhi and seeing a man completely
[ __ ] his way through an isakai it's
just the edgy dumb fun I need in my life
ooh a fresh pie save me a slice
that's good okay that's good yeah that's
all right that's good okay okay all
right okay all right okay that's good
that's good it's it's enough slices now
if you're a season anime fan you are in
for an absolute treat right now because
this is the season of amazing no no you
[ __ ] sequels spikes family is
continuing to be one of the hottest new
anime this year mob psycho season 3
showcasing some of the best animation
the medium has ever seen to your
eternity coming back to give more tears
I said not you my hero Academia hitting
us with its best Arc in a while Pub team
epic carrying on his Insanity we got
more golden camuy more rumikum bleach is
back baby now I know this is a series
that meant a lot to many people but you
know just because it's bleach doesn't
mean it's gonna be a guaranteed Banger
so you know let's all just try to calm
down and keep our hyping check going
into this
[Music]
yeah it was right okay I've been vocal
about my criticisms of bleach over the
years post-soul society and Aaron car
Arc it was my least favorite of the big
three I really do think latter part of
the manga took a nosedive in quality but
I'd be lying if I didn't say it feels
[ __ ] good to see the squad back again
like I thought I was going to keep it
together and then that one song came on
you know the song You know the song you
know I'm talking about the one that's
like so babe and now you feel like
number one Shannon Brad forever
I'm gonna have a kid I'm Gonna Be Like
Son let me Regale you of the songs of my
childhood if you wanna see some action
God I miss bleach Nostalgia goggles
aside though bleach has never looked
this good they are pulling out all the
stops in the Mario I felt this Last Arc
was a little rush but with Kubo actually
being involved in production this might
not just be an opportunity to see bleach
once again but there might be a chance
it could also improve on some of the
manga shortcomings
oh
simple
[Music]
from the creators of re creators comes
whatever the [ __ ] this show is he got an
average guy good at gymnastics has a
cool anchor and a hard time
starts his first day at school and he's
like what do we say to the god of Visa
guy
not today next day he gets confessed to
gets a girlfriend jackpot goes on the
first date she immediately invites him
back to her place double jackpot they're
doing Netflix and chill she takes a top
off climbs on top of him and he's like
what do we say to the god of [ __ ] not
everyone roll credits that's episode one
honestly this just seems like dumb fun
do you hate fun why do people hate fun
this is why not enough people watch
recreaters stop hating fun hey what's
that is that a Gundam Gundam
gun damn gun damn damn gone what are you
guys wink
watching Neon Genesis Evangelion since
performed sure a lot of us were even
born Gundam has been pretty much the
face of giant robots leading leading
liquor industry to the modern day but
exactly the ease franchise to get into
it's been seven years seven years since
the last newbie friendly Gundam so
there's probably a decent chunk of new
anime fans who's never even seen a
single Gundam which is why we've
desperately needed a show like Gundam
the witch from Mercury not only is this
a new original story not related to
previous franchises but it looks
fantastic sounds fantastic there are
actually 2D mechs I repeat there are 2D
mechs and the prologue alone is a
goddamn short movie that hits like a
truck this is the Gundam I've been
waiting for this is the Gundam we've
needed this is the most excited I've
been for a wrecker show in years so if
you haven't seen a Gundam before if
you've never watched a Mecca show before
now is the time to start because you
can't spell Gundam without gun damn and
you can't spell at least Kai without IC
slavery okay yeah I don't know I was
going with that all right I know having
a guy reincarnated as a sword might make
it look like we're just running out of
isika ideas and we're just going with
any old gimmick at this point
hold on hold on
hear me out
you're absolutely right okay though for
real the swordy Sakai is actually
surprisingly decent with some
interesting ideas for an isakai show I
mean for one they actually free the
slaves instead of buying them nice to
see we're finally making strides in the
fantasy genre because next we have Beast
Tamers a nice little wholesome fantasy
show about a guy who tames Beast girls
let's see what this is about
[Music]
wait a minute this is just repackaged
slavery speaking of taming we've got
another villainous Issa card this time
the protagonist gets Easter card into
the body of an otome game villainous
called Eileen but she's not gonna try
and romance any of the male Heroes no no
this time she goes for the sigma male
Demon Lord himself and so begins this
elongated adventure of her trying to
convince the Big Daddy sexy Demon Lord
too
I like this one there's no secret I'm
not the biggest fan of cute girls do
cute things but every once in a while a
show in the genre just grabs me for a
reason my brains still can't comprehend
and for whatever reason do it yourself
is doing just that for me the All-Stars
isn't just your copy paste Moe Bob
bubble gum style The Vibes are on points
this is like if aziken decided to make
Ikea furniture I will say though the
anime really wants you to know that the
main character's name is your set of
food
and the anime is called do it yourself
ah get it who
[Music]
cares what's next Bocce The Rock
looks like we've got more cute girls
doing cute things this season this time
a bunch of them making a band guys
something we've not seen done since
chaon or chaon season two okay on the
movie or chaon but [ __ ] I'm not gonna
lie this one actually looks good too
Slice of Life fans be eating good this
season and it looks like there's gonna
be a real focus on music and
performances too they've done a good job
of making this not feel like okay on
clone because it's a different vibe
different setting and the main girl is
so socially awkward she makes Comey son
look like tyler1 so really it's KR
ah she just like me for real oh there's
a new anime where the story is um
um
what the dog doing biblio fall princess
I love books we've got a story about
some Noble's daughter who's a book nerd
from the kingdom of sausland
being set up in an arranged marriage
she's got no interest in why does she
agree to it well she gets access to
their library with thousands of books of
course now if you've never read a book
it's kind of similar to anime except
unlike anime there are no visuals but
the story unfolds in the magical place
of your mind that opens up your
imagination to infinite possibilities
and also here it gets you [ __ ]
[Music]
okay I'm now convinced domestic
girlfriend and rent a girlfriend have
broken something in me this actually
seems like he has potential to be a
great romance anime the art style is
gorgeous the use of the different
colored outlines in places gives a
really unique aesthetic the dynamic
between the main Duo is really cute and
is even a little twist to the formula
with a schooling system that pairs
students up for mock marriages leading
to love triangles Galore this has all
the ingredients for a great romance
anime and I know this
and I see this
but I look at this now and I'm like
within a romance cringe
I must flow you know what else is cringe
[ __ ] maid cafes am I right
oh I'm gonna say it PA works is doing
some weird [ __ ] [ __ ] recently and I
love it ancient Chinese strategist
reincarnated into the modern day Shibuya
to become a manager of a singer nah not
weird enough how about a homage to Old
School yuckers are moving in gang wars
except let's replace all the Yakuza with
maid cafes and have the gang wars take
place in the streets of Akihabara
all right
you go right on you everyone involved
absolutely understands their assignments
you can tell the people behind this are
having so much fun and it shines through
this series is as insane as it is a joy
to watch it's funny dark and brilliantly
satirical and if this keeps up it might
just do the impossible get me to
actually go to a maid Cafe again
oh yes finally our Sports protagonist I
can get behind
all right be honest how many times have
you seen a Sports Anime and it's like oh
teamwork guys let's get to Nationals
with the power of friendship friendship
get that [ __ ] out of here we go bloody
football squid game up in there and it's
all about being selfish egotistical
Grady [ __ ] teamwork [ __ ] friendship
Japan's making their own Zlatan
Ibrahimovic that's [ __ ] football
right there none of that pansy ass dick
talking faking your injury [ __ ] man
puke men poop on the pitch men deliver
newborn babies on the touch lines
[ __ ] hardcore [ __ ] ass Ticky
Tucker football [ __ ] it take it to extra
time [ __ ] clutch in the 90th minute
score a 30-yard screamer because this is
the beautiful game football is back baby
so I was thinking about pulling for Nida
and neither what's that I was the
character from genshin Impact do you
play genshin impact I mean I guess can
you say that again for me say what I
play genshin impact I play genshin
impact
we got him boys this man plays gentian
impact there she is I can't believe in
20 22 I get to see the original hot
anime girl the legendary primordial
waifu herself
who would you say yatsuna is a classic
anime from the 70s coming from the
legendary rumiko Takahashi that is
arguably the beginning of waifu culture
itself before Asaka and Rey before REM
before Arsenal before zero two there was
arguably the first waifu in anime so for
anyone with an OG we bother out there
now is the perfect chance for a
father-son wanting session when you go
Dad
I just lost no not November to the same
imaginary girl you did I'm impressed
that just how well they've captured the
old school Vibes without making it feel
like it stated I just hope to God
there's a British dub of this because if
you didn't know the BBC actually picked
up a few episodes of the original yurusa
yatsura and dubbed it in British English
move this way to help you well done
fatted you brought tears to the eyes
what do you say turtle will you save the
planet and all mankind
[ __ ] off
all right time for the big one in all my
years of watching anime I've never seen
an uip get the kind of hype chainsaw man
got the trailers blew up on the Internet
everyone was talking about it there were
no Margaritas suddenly appearing for
under the nearest rock telling you this
was going to be the next big theme
because this time everyone already knew
it chainsaw man wasn't just the most
anticipated anime of the Season it was
the most anticipated anime of the year
now did it descend from the heavens save
anime impregnate Dwayne The Rock Johnson
and transcend the medium to give his
author the levantation powers he always
wanted
no episode one could have come in free
cocaine and blow jobs and it wouldn't
have met the hype it received prior to
release but what it did deliver is one
of the most promising adaptations in a
long time it's a rare case when a Heidi
beloved piece of work is given the same
amount of love and resources it needs to
bring it to life but that seems to be
exactly what's happening here even with
the amount of killer IP Studio mapper
have under the belt right now it seems
like they've put their a team into this
chainsaw man looks gorgeous and I'm not
just talking about the flashy action
scenes from the quietest moments the
smallest movements every frame looks
like a goddamn wallpaper every shot
looks like it was meticulously crafted
the team didn't just try to reference
tatsuki fujimoto's love for Cinema the
entire thing feels cinematic I mean just
look at this cinematography
for real though this isn't some surface
level adaptation you can sense the team
trying their best to imbue the soul of
the original work into this anime
everyone seems to have bet and bet big
on this show we have 12 different ending
songs and animations for each episode
and if you like go to the uploads on
YouTube each of the artists have
commented themselves on their ending
episodes and what it meant to them like
where the hell else do you see [ __ ] like
this every single person seems to be
excited to be working on this project
and this is the kind of love and care
you can't buy with just money this is
shaping up to be a magical production so
if the story ends up being as good as
the fandom says it is it is going to be
nearby impossible to find a better thing
to watch this season my only complaint
is that in episode 1 at least there were
just a few shots where the CG looked a
bit awkward and I know a lot of people
have pointed this out alright what's
next
foreign
man CG looks amazing
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too Alpha
Sigma basil dysfunctional degenerates
ivito Jeff lovardos
misaka12315 Payne Patchett Pony Stark
waltergeist VT and everyone else my
patreon for helping to spawn for this
month and making this video possible I
know I said at the beginning of this
video but I'll say it again I know this
seasonal video is a little bit late guys
this might be the latest I've ever
posted a seasonal video in the season so
uh maybe someone can tell me if it is
but again I hope you understand
considering I was in America for 42 days
yeah I couldn't really get much other
work done there but I am happy to be
back in Japan now and I'm happy to be in
one place and all flying around or
living my life out of the bus it's nice
to actually sleep on my bed so I'm not
only going to be making more content on
this channel but uh I'm gonna be
starting my stream back up on twitch.tv
gig up so uh yeah more gentian am I
right anyway though that's it from me
today nothing more to say I've been gig
up and I'll see you all next time